Speaker 1: I hate to have to start here today,
but I have a sort of epidemiological gun to
my head for metaphorical purposes called the
Delta variant and called a.
Voxer ism.
And it's just bad news about this pandemic
that we just can't seem to shake, thanks to
people refusing to get vaccinated.
And thanks to the highly contagious Delta
variant, average daily cases here in the United
States are up one hundred and twenty two percent
in just over three weeks, more than doubling
in just three weeks, up from their bottom
of about 12000 cases a day.
We had gotten down to about 12000 cases a
day, by the way, still more than the ten thousand
case per day mark that Dr. Anthony Fauci established
over a year ago as sort of like we need to
get below that to say it's under control.
We almost got down to that.
And now cases back up one hundred and twenty
two percent to about twenty seven thousand
a day.
This is really quick.
And it's because of the rapidly spreading
60 percent more contagious Delta variant,
combined with too many people just choosing
not to get vaccinated.
There's vaccines everywhere.
They're coming out there.
You can't walk through a pharmacy without
just stumbling over vaccines.
And 20 percent of the country does not interested.
And the good news is and we'll get back to
this, if you are vaccinated, you are really
well protected against the Delta variant.
If you were vaccinated and you get the virus
in one of these what are called breakthrough
infections, you're likely not to have symptoms.
And if you do have a symptomatic vaccinated
case, it's likely not to be serious.
You're not likely to be hospitalized.
You're not likely to die.
But nothing is perfect.
Everything is bell curve distribution.
And some vaccinated people who do everything
right will get sick and they will die.
And every person who chooses not to get vaccinated
makes that more likely.
We wondered, though, cases are up, but will
deaths be up?
Because with so many people vaccinated, we
might see cases, but we won't see deaths go
up.
We said three weeks ago we need three weeks
to answer that question because deaths lag
cases by three weeks.
And sadly, the answer there is yes as well.
You have to look carefully because it's still
a small uptick in terms of raw numbers.
But on a percentage basis, deaths are now
up almost 20 percent deaths per day in the
US from covid bottomed out about a week ago.
At two hundred and eighteen per day, they
have tick back up 20 percent to two fifty
nine per day.
We have only fully vaccinated about half of
the United States.
If you look at vaccinations per day, you see
that we are now back down to the daily vaccination
levels of early January when we had almost
no vaccine availability.
We're now doing a pathetic, flaccid, weak
five hundred thousand doses a day.
We have all the vaccines.
You can just walk in almost anywhere and we're
only doing five hundred thousand doses a day.
And since many of those are parts of a two
dose regimen, we're really only completing
a vaccination protocol for probably about
three hundred and fifty thousand people per
day, zero point one percent of the population
per day.
It's humiliating.
It's pathetic.
And the virus is spreading.
It's not some abstract thing.
Oh, vaccinations are down, but it has no real
impact.
Cases up.
One hundred and twenty two percent.
That's up almost 20 percent.
Not just happening in the US, although it's
particularly bad here.
Globally, cases are now back up thirty one
percent from their low.
Globally, deaths are now back up about three
Remember, deaths follow cases by three to
four weeks.
Nearly half of Republicans in the United States
just don't want the vaccine.
People in other countries are falling all
over themselves to try to get the limited
vaccines that are available.
And in the United States, nearly half of Republicans
say, no, I don't want to go and get it.
It's horrifying stuff.
Dr. Eric Topol, who has been a guest on the
program before, posted to his Twitter.
There are places in the United States with
vaccination rates as low as 15 percent, one
five, Newton, Missouri, 16 percent.
Vaccination Douglas, 15 percent.
Rennolds, 15 percent.
This is unconscionable.
Now, if there is any good news, we'll go back
to something I mentioned at the top of the
segment.
It is once again the reassurance that the
vaccines work really well.
We can't control the fact that even as vaccinated
people, we are more at risk thanks to people
who refuse to get vaccinated that we can't
we can't directly control.
We can try to convince them, but we can't
change the math of that.
But being able to get vaccinated oneself.
Is a big piece because the latest numbers
are that ninety nine percent of those who
are currently hospitalized are unvaccinated
people.
So the level of protection that you can unilaterally
give yourself just by going in and getting
getting vaccinated is absolutely huge.
It's not perfect, but it's absolutely huge.
And that's the reassuring thing.
The hope would be and this is, you know, depending
on whether you look at Pfizer or Moderna and
you look at it, there's a lot of details in
this.
The hope would be maybe by the end of fall,
by winter, maybe not until early.
Twenty, twenty two.
The vaccine that will be available will be
one that is already tailored for the Delta
variant.
But as we know, the more it spreads, the more
opportunity to mutate and to go to some new
variant that the vaccine will not be tailored
to.
There's now talk of this LAMDA variant from
Australia.
We don't know much about it.
There's the possibility that it's even more
contagious than Delta.
We don't know about the mortality rate.
These are all questions.
And because we don't have answers to those
questions, what question do we have an answer
to right now?
Well, the question is, how can you give yourself
drastic protection and protect others?
It's just you go and get vaccinated.
It's that simple.
So it's depressing.
I'm not going to lie.
It is very, very depressing.
But it is where we are today and hopefully
we will be able to accelerate vaccination.
I don't know what it will take at this point.
I know that a third of those who say I don't
want it say if it's if it receives full approval
from the FDA, I will go and get vaccinated.
One third of those who don't currently want
the vaccine say I will get it if it gets full,
full authorization, full approval from the
FDA.
That's coming soon.
So we will soon see if we are going to see
tha